diverticular disease is a condition
occurring when pouches form toward the
end of the large intestine your large
intestine also known as your colon
includes the cecum ascending colon
transverse colon descending colon
sigmoid colon rectum and anal canal
the wall of your colon has four main
layers the mucosa the submucosa a
muscular layer and the outer serosa
blood vessels called Vasa recta supply
blood to your colon
although the cause is unknown
diverticulosis is associated with a low
fiber diet constipation and frequent
straining with bowel movements
constipation causes increased pressure
inside your colon
increased pressure may cause the mucosa
and submucosa to herniate through a
weakened area of the wall of your colon
and form a diverticulum
diverticulosis occurs when you have
these diverticula but often no other
symptoms
in contrast diverticulitis occurs when
the diverticula become inflamed
the usual symptoms of diverticulitis are
lower left abdominal pain fever
constipation or diarrhea and decreased
appetite
diverticulitis may develop an
accumulation of pus called an abscess
excessive swelling and accumulation of
pus may lead to the formation of a
perforation allowing pus and other
material to escape into your abdomen
this is a very serious condition and
requires immediate medical attention
if you have a severe case of
diverticulitis you may need to have a
procedure to drain an abscess
if the condition persists you may
require surgery to remove the affected
part of your colon during your procedure
your surgeon will pass the remaining end
of your colon through your abdominal
wall creating an opening called a stoma
after your colon heals it can be
reattached to your rectum
the main treatment for diverticulosis is
increased consumption of fiber rich
foods to soften and add bulk to stools
which help stimulate the colon to
contract and eliminate them
other treatments for diverticulitis
include a clear liquid diet and oral
antibiotics